Och sen så kill your darlings.
Jag fick en av många gånger att hitta en it-lösning.
Det här blir så bra, det blir så bra.
Så man bara, jag måste döda den här för det här kommer ta för lång tid, eller vi har inte organisation nog, eller min idé var inte så bra.
Men så döda dina älsklingar när det gäller sitt eget.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta, du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har ren dess bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Välkommen till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Idag sitter vi här med Nick Steger och först kanske vi ska fråga, jag brukar aldrig fråga hur man uttalar efternamn, för jag tycker att de säger det i varenda podd, jag tycker det är en tröttsam mening, men säger man Steger?
För det är lite...
Ja, men det var jättebra att uttala.
Min dotter är jätteirriterad på att hon inte kan uttala sitt eget efternamn, men tyskarna säger det, jag är halvtysk och min pappa bor nere i München, och där är det väl mer Stega.
Och sådär, Stega, okej.
Men jag får det lite olika.
Ja men det låter, det är lite artistnamn, över det kan jag tycka, Nick Stegg.
Ja men om det var nog, Mick Jäger har någon kallat mig någon gång.
Såklart, ja.
Det är därför jag tänker att det är såhär undermedvetet.
Kan vi inte ta om, du är ju en Alt-Jallo-person, så det är lite svårt att beskriva dig, annars får jag sitta här och rabla på, men vad säger du själv liksom?
Ja, det är väl en...
Jag är egentligen en civilingenjör i någon form av botten, och då blir man ju problemlösare.
Egentligen hade jag någon idé om att bli entreprenör, men brände mig när jag var ganska ung på några startups.
Alltså jag var jätteung, 15-16 år, och då valutade jag att jag måste gå akademispåret.
Och där ramlade jag in i operations, körde jättehårt på ett tungt operations-spår på General Electric, lärde mig lin, sex sigma, logistik, alltså riktig logistik, alltså global logistik, lärde mig produktion och datadrivet när det inte finns någon data.
Jag brukar säga att det är i fysisk produktion så är det jättesvårt att samla in datan och så blir man jättenoggrant på att analysera datan.
Efter det var det tre, fyra år, då ramlade jag in, då var det hela transformationen att alla bolag skulle bli agila.
Då började jag hjälpa företag med agilitet för det är väldigt likt lin, det är som Systemtank och så här, och det är mycket gamla större bolag med sin IT-avdelning.
Och som någon anledning i det här så ramlade jag in på ICAS, eller andra e-handelssatsningar för den som de har idag, de hade ju en 2005 tror jag redan, och drev all produktinformationsspåret där.
Och så vill jag säga som du kan logistik, operations, du kan IT, alltså kravställa bra IT-utveckling, och så kan du retail.
Då blir det liksom, det blir e-handel kvar då.
För att det är där det är området jag får använda alla tre ben.
Och som du sa även när vi såg att e-handel är egentligen logistik.
Men bra logistik kräver bra IT, och bra kräver att man hjälper kunden.
Så det har blivit hela spåret, alltså digital utveckling, nåt plummigt sett.
Men därför blir det väl lite allt i allo.
Det här Six Sigma och Lean, det är ju sådana här uttryck som du vet de återkommer hela tiden.
Har inte världen kommit med nåt nytt sedan dess?
Är det fortfarande the shit liksom?
Det är ju en otroligt bra fråga.
Vissa saker är ju så pass bra, så att de ska vara kvar.
Vissa saker blir nästan eviga för att de är bra.
Och sen så, jag har ju träffat folk som säger så här, men Lean det är ju bara sund förnuft.
Ja, absolut.
Det är otroligt, och det är väl det som är det kraftfulla.
Man tar vissa verktygen, nån som heter 5S, det är fem stycken japanska ord som börjar på S, som handlar om städa och sortera.
Det är verkligen management by mormor.
Det skulle du lika gärna kunna heta.
Ha ordning och reda på din skit.
Men just Linn så är det ett otroligt bra kraftfullt sätt att höja upp det, att göra det som subtilt undermedvetet.
Det här är ett så bra sätt att lyfta upp det på, så att man får ett språk internt där alla fattar att nu måste vi göra fem S på det här, nu måste vi göra en kaisen, det är det japanska ordet för ständig förbättring eller förbättring.
Då helt plötsligt får man ett helt annat effektivare språk kring hur vi hela tiden jobbar med förbättringar.
Så det är väl den kraften i det.
Och sex sigma i sig, det är ju en otroligt många starka statistiska modeller.
Och när du får statistisk kontroll på någon process, det är då du kan skala den på riktigt.
Så sex sigma är ju mycket svårare.
Det heter ju Lin sex sigma, den sex sigma delen.
Det handlar egentligen om, sex sigma är ju hur många standardavvikelser du ska vara ifrån standardprocessen.
Och om du är, sigma är ju liksom måttrande standardprincipen, och om du är sex sigma ifrån det värsta till det sämsta, så betyder det att du har 3,14 fel per miljoner möjligheter.
Och om du är där i det processen, om man tänker, vissa processer måste vara ännu bättre, men nästan alla processer som vi jobbar med, vilket vi klarar oss på 3 sigma, alltså ungefär 3 fel per tusen.
Men om du är ett telekombolag eller ett bolag i SLSJ, så är det så otroligt många möjligheter, det kan bli fel.
Och då räcker det med att man ligger på 3 fel på en miljon möjligheter, och så kommer det att bli tidningsrubriket på det.
Eller om de dör av det.
Så det beror på vad du har för process, vilken nivå du ska ligga på.
Men därifrån kommer det här tankesättet.
Går du runt och pratar i en lite språk, jag kan uppleva att det finns vissa sådana här, vad ska vi kalla det då?
Tanketeorier eller sätt där folk liksom, du skriver det som ett språk.
NLP var ju jättestort för ett tag sen typ 15 år, jag vet inte men, men då var det också såhär, folk började prata om förklaringsmodeller och man bara, herregud, pratar du om sånt utifrån människor?
Går du runt i de här olika, när du har skolats in i detta, är det så du bedömer världen?
Har du de glasar gående på dig?
Det är otroligt bra att bilda glasögonen på sig.
Jag har ju också otroligt olika roller, men om det gäller på ett lager eller om jag ska sätta upp en process, då sätter jag absolut på mig de här slöseri-glasögonen.
Där finns det något som kallas 7 Waste.
Då är det ett sätt att identifiera vart det finns slöserier.
Det är alldeles väntetid, skador, överproduktion, transport, onödiga rörelser.
Den värsta överproduktionen producerar något som ingen kommer att köpa.
Då har du gjort alla andra slöserier innan.
Den här är integrerad i mitt sätt att tänka på.
Det här går att använda på marknadsföring också.
Om du köper för mycket synlighet på Google och det konverterar inte, då är du på att överproducera och då har du byggt en kampanj som du förstår.
Den här grejen är riktigt kraftfullt, men det är först kraftfullt när du integrerar det i din sätt att vara.
Orden i sig har ingen kraft.
Vad gör du när du inte lär människor vad sådana här ord betyder?
Jag har ju hört dig, du är med i poddar, du är med i paneler, du är med i föreläsningar, du skriver någon bok, du skriver en till bok.
Vad pysslar du med?
Vad jobbar du med nu?
Det är så bra.
Jag tror att det gäller dina engelsk, du och jag har lite liknande drivkrafter kring varför man gillar att kommunicera också.
Jag tycker att jag får väldigt mycket energi av att kommunicera.
Men min största rädsla är att bli sedd som en kommunikatör och som punkt.
Vad menar du med det?
Det här är killen som babblar om saker men aldrig gör saker.
För min del är det otroligt viktigt för mig att ha riktiga projekt på marken.
Och verkligen göra grundjobbet och det där är det roligaste trots allt.
Och det roligaste är att äntes med era team.
Jag sitter i några firelser också men det som jag gör konkret nu är egen konsult.
Egentligen letar jag efter ett femårsgig.
Jag älskar att skala till tillväxt.
Jag längtar efter ett 100 miljonersbolag som ska upp till miljarden.
Där är jag bra.
Jag har insett att det som du har gjort mål till 100 miljoner, det är jag så sjukt imponerad av som folk som gör.
Det kräver så mycket.
Det kräver saker som jag kanske har om, men jag har aldrig testat.
Men jag tog extremt stor respekt för det.
Men det jag gör nu så hjälper jag olika bolag.
Jag såg senast Interim's COO eller vice vd på ett musikskibolag, distributionsbolag, som var redan digitalt, som påminner ganska mycket om e-handel, kundans skaffning och it-processer.
Har varit där tio månader men har precis lämnat förbrytat en lösning där och Amuse heter de och gått in på tre.
Anledningen varför vi började samtalet i Lean är för att jag är där och processkartlägger driver deras processkartläggningsarbete.
Spaning bara av anledningen varför processkartläggning och Lean igen blir intressant, det tror jag att det är.
När man gör en assessment på att bli AI-redo i stora bolag, så är det så här om du inte har ordning på nya processer så ser du inte ens vart du ska stoppa in AI.
För det är så utspritt i människors individers huvud, så det är lite att göra sig AI-redo, det jag jobbar med nu, till kombolaget helt enkelt.
Jag rör mig, jag väntar jättekäst med att jag har jobbat i snart alla branscher utom mode brukar jag säga.
Men kan man göra så?
Är man så flexibel som människa att man kan hoppa från, nu vet jag inte hur stora Muse är men de är ju inte tre.
Nej, de är bara om så att en halv miljard.
Jaha okej, då så.
Men det är så det är.
Men du har ju gått från, gjorde du elcykelpunkten till exempel?
Det är ju ett väldigt annorlunda bolag än tre till exempel.
Verkligen.
Funkar det så?
Kan du verkligen använda samma förmågor eller tänk på så olika branscher och storlekar?
Nej men det är ju en otroligt bra fråga.
Det finns en nedre gräns.
Det finns också en övrig gräns, det finns gränser.
Det som jag ser som min förmåga är att kunna komma in och utmana status quo.
Och sen inte bara riva utan utmana det, minska nere och göra det där det har blivit för krångligt, gör det enkelt.
Men om man är i en ägarledd eller mindre bolag, så finns det nästan ingen status quo.
Allt är redan utmanat.
Och om man då har en personlighet som jag har som utmanar i det läget då är det extremt lätt att man river det som fanns och inte har kapacitet att bygga upp det.
Det är ett stort bolag, det är inte en skärp styrkan.
Där behöver man få in energi, och i energi börjar det röra på sig och man kan inte vara så fast i sina strukturer.
Där finns det en utmaning för mig att kunna hantera.
Men säg ett bolag som är runt en halv miljard, eller på Nordse Galeriet som är runt en miljard, då tar jag oftast rollen att stryka det upp, sätta upp det och göra det så enkelt som det bara går.
Men jag tror att om du och jag skulle jobba tillsammans så hade det inte varit...
Det är det vi tänkte på personlighetsnivå, men att vi båda inte hade fått en hävstång i vår effektivitet som vi skulle kunna få om vi var på halv miljard och vi tog varsin del av bolaget snarare.
Förstår du?
Jag fattar det.
Hur vet du vad du ska utmana och vad du inte ska utmana?
Eller ska allt utmanas?
Shit det där är ett bra fråga.
Jag skulle mest vilja ha ditt svar på den också sen.
Men jag tänker...
Det är återigen så att man kan ju...
Nu har jag börjat gå in i mitt lineteänkare som jag har i uppdraget och då blir det ofta så att jag...
Tänk på de här sjuslöserierna.
Och då när man har de ögonen på sig, att man vet ju att om lageromsättningssatsen är för hög, eller för låg men det, då är det ett väldigt bra symptom att försöka förstå varför det är för högt eller för lågt men det.
Och om man ska omsätta lager sex gånger om året och det ligger på fyra, och det är det enda sättet för att få cashflow på det, då kan man direkt börja gå in i procure to pay-processen och börja förse över och då ser man ganska, det är rätt fort vad man ser vad som är problemet då.
Allt från att man har sina payment terms eller att man betalar för tidigt eller att man har lägger order i fel datum eller det ligger för länge innan det kommer upp på lagret, innan det kommer upp på site.
Kan vi lita på den här leverantören så att vi kan ha det säljbart även om det inte finns på lagret?
Vilka leverantörer kan vi lita på på det sättet?
Alltså, det kan vi nästan göra på en dag i ett mindre bolag, att få svar på hela den här anledningen.
Varför snurrar vi inte lagret så fort som vi ska?
Och då hittar vi de här nyckelsymptomen, och det är ju en vissa nyckelkopier, där jag har fått en relation till datan, för jag har sett så mycket data under tiden och nästan säger att det där borde finnas någonting att göra.
Där finns det slöserier, för andra bolag har en helt annan nyckeltal på just den där delen.
Och så fort det blir arbetssätt, så är det ganska fort att lösa det.
Så fort vi landar i att vi måste göra en IT eller en systemlösning, då tar det ofta lite längre tid.
Dock blir det mycket mer stabilt om vi kör systemlösningslösningen.
Hur skäldar jag med, du måste ju sitta och leta slöserier 24-7.
Ja, så är det ju.
Och en stor del är ju bara att sitta och ifrågasätta sina egna lösningar hela tiden.
Bra, tack.
Där är det fan, vad, ja men det är ju lite så.
Alltså så här har jag gjort nu, det är bra liksom.
Och så sitter man så och håller på och ifrågasätter hela tiden.
Och så hittar man en procent där, en procent där, två där och så bara.
Och så är det som du säger, ibland kommer man på IT-grejer och då tar det typ ett år men det blir skitbra.
Men absolut, det är klart det är så.
Och då får man liksom hitta ett sätt att pocka det först.
Och sen så kill your darling.
Sen har man många gånger hittat en IT-lösning.
Så man säger att det här blir så bra, det blir så bra.
Så man bara, nej jag måste döda den här för framtiden.
För att det här kommer ta på lång tid eller vi har inte organisation nog.
Eller, min idé var inte så bra, men så döda dina älsklingar när det gäller sitt eget.
Men när du kommer in såhär, för jag kan se, nu har ju inte vi träffats jättemycket, men jag har träffat er vid ett tillfälle och du har ju en, jag brukar minnas folk i vibrationer, typ hur intensivt deras vibrationer går.
Och dina inna, dina vibrationer går ju lite mer intensivt än mina.
Så att om du kommer in här och så kör du på och liksom såhär, nu röj vi upp här, vi fixar det här, vi gör såhär, såhär, såhär.
Hur ser du till att det stannar kvar sen?
Ja verkligen, det är en så otroligt bra fråga.
Det är väl, sättet man gör det på, det är ju att det är, jag är ganska individfokuserad också.
Och det blir ju att skapa sig liksom vänner samtidigt som och liksom...
Anhängare, är det så du säger det?
Ja men kanske.
De ska uppskatta det sättet du arbetar på.
Ja men exakt, att få lite fans men också att det finns en stor del.
Det beror på vad beställningen är.
Om det är att se över hur vi för upplager, omställda som jag ser, då är det ju väldigt mycket infinance och kanske inte så mycket...
Det värsta jag skulle vilja göra omställda för dig, det skulle vara att ge mig analysen.
För så fort analysen är...
Det är kanske 50% av jobbet tidsmässigt, men det är kanske bara 10% av det som är det hårda jobbet att göra.
Så jag skulle också vilja börja implementera det så att man verkligen får med sig det.
För skrivbordsprodukterna har vi nog av, skulle jag säga, det är ingen som blir lycklig över en till rapport.
Och det här är också en sak som jag alltid säger till teamet, att om det inte touchar kund så har vi bara skapat slöseri.
Och det här är både till produktutvecklingsteam, även till säljteam, så att om vi håller på att ta fram en ny produkt, och säljer 99% klart men ingen trycker att lägga ut den på sajten, att det är en frisprodukt, så har vi inte gjort någonting.
För det är först när kunden ser den som vi har skapat värdet.
Och man kan använda det som en intern grej att du är nästa person i processsteget ska se det.
Men rejält så ska det vara när slutkunden når det.
Och även, jag kommer att vara på Snord då, och jag heter dem i Agiltransformation.
Då var det såhär, 70% av all kod kom alltid i produktion.
Det här är det klassiska överproduktion.
Det här är en så otroligt slöseri.
Att försöka få in det här tänket medan man jobbar.
Det måste bidra sig av kunden för att det ska ha värde.
Det skapar en kultur av time to market.
Men det skapar också en kultur av att minska slöseriet.
Och då kanske man dödar saker innan.
Om det här kommer aldrig att nå kunden.
För det här är lite för krångligt för att göra det här.
Det tror jag är ett tillvägagångssätt.
Och sen får man ha vissa principer.
Varför det här ska vara...
Man får förstå att alla projekt är kultur en förändringsprojekt.
För varje människa har påverkan på en annan människa.
Och kultur är det som händer mellan människor.
Men är det ditt jobb att driva förändringen eller är det bara ditt jobb att hitta punkter?
När du går in på tre här, ska du faktiskt implementera grejer och se till att folk gör?
Ja, här är det mer så.
På Amuse var det mycket mer interimsroll.
Och där blev det också så såklart, för där blev det mer ledarskap generellt.
Och sen på...
Men är det det som är din passion?
För att det är en jävla skillnad på att...
Jag har ju en kollega som jobbar med, eller en kompis som jobbar med...
Han går in i fabriker och hittar slöseri eller vad man ska säga och se till att göra.
Och han drivs ju av den processen, han drivs ju kanske inte av ledarskapsprocessen.
Det är ju väldigt olika processer eller personlighetstyper kan jag tycka.
Men går du in i båda de rollerna och vill du det?
Ja, precis.
Det här är ju, det kanske är lite som du vill vara inne på att jag är spretig.
För egentligen så det jag brinner för är kundvärde på något sätt.
Och därför brinner jag, och det är det bästa sättet att mäta kundvärde det är när folk väljer att handla från dig.
Och för då röstar kunderna med sin plånbok, speciellt om de håller på med retail.
Men så är det här nödvändigheter för att få folk att rösta på dig.
Så det är egentligen rent och skärt försäljningsdriven.
Men förstår att försäljningen bygger inte på vad du har använt för SEO, eller vad du har använt för tag i mailet.
Utan det bygger på vad du har för produkt först, och hur fort du kan leverera produkten.
Det bygger på alla processerna.
För kunden märker av det, om inte direkt så märker man av det indirekt.
Så egentligen är det det som är min passion, att få så många människor som möjligt att rösta med sin plånbok på dig.
Och då är det här väldigt starka verktyg.
Nej, jag tror jag skiljer mig ganska mycket från din kompis där.
För jag känner sådana, jag har sådana kompisar också som har shadow boards i sina egna kök.
Därom för att få så bra optimering av sitt eget kök som möjligt.
Men, ja.
Exakt.
Det är ju en viss typ av människor att tänka på.
Du har ju varit på ganska många uppdrag, du såg även styrelser här och allt sånt här.
Kan du sakna att hänga på ett ställe i fem år?
Eller är det?
Ja, verkligen.
Det är där med fem år här tidigare, men liksom, varför gör du inte det då?
Nej men det är väl, jag, ja men exakt så.
Jag saknar det.
Jag saknar, jag tycker det är så härligt att stå vid rodret.
Och då blir det med den analogin så är det liksom inte just det att få bestämma, utan det är snarare att man liksom gör det med team och att man får lida av sina beslut.
För det får man göra på ett annat sätt.
Ja men verkligen, man får göra det på ett annat sätt när man är, och man får också njuta av sina beslut.
Men jag tycker att ledarskap på vilka bolag är väl rätt mycket lydande ändå, eller vad säger du själv?
Ja, det är nog en faktor på 9-10, eller 9 mot 1.
Ja 9 mot 1, eller hur?
Det är en ratio som är inte superpositiv.
Men av någon anledning finns det en otrolig stolthet i när man och teamet har byggt ihop.
Det är det där som min längtan är, sns och sådant grejer.
Jag väljer inte av VD eller så, utan det är snarare ledande position, oftast blir det försäljning eftersom jag förstår data, förstår kunden och förstår tekniken.
Så det låter som en annons för att vänta jobb.
Men nu, för du har ju snackat lite om, jag tänkte segoya in det här på kundresan.
För du har först, nu ska du skriva en bok, eller du håller på att skriva en bok som heter Kundhjävlar.
Det är en fin titel.
Men det är också för att du redan har skrivit en bok som heter En Gävle på e-handel, som du skrev med han Arashgilan, som gör vd-podden, folk känner nog igen det.
Exakt.
Är det weird att skriva en bok om e-handel som förändras sjukt fort, för att den är ju typ gammal när den släpps.
Ja exakt.
Ännu inte är den, men du fattar vad jag menar.
Ja men jag fattar precis.
Och det är vissa delar som är mycket mer obsolita än andra.
Jag tror att vi har något kapitel om Snapchat typ, och det är väl typ, den måste man inte läsa om man köper boken.
Men samtidigt så är det kapitel om prissättning som jag är ganska stolt över.
Det finns ett kapitel om saklementskartläggning där som vi faktiskt kommer att skriva ännu mer om i nästa bok.
Och det är ju teori som är gammal om jag ska vara helt ärlig, men som bara sätts i digital kontext.
Och som Arash alltid säger så är det som människan ändras inte utan tekniken ändras.
Det finns några sådana, de första kapitlerna handlar mer om människan, vissa verktygen handlar om människan.
Så det finns mycket saker som håller sig kvar som vi inte har hänt så stor skillnad med.
Sedan så medvetet har vi nästan inte ens nämnt Google i boken.
Det finns mycket andra böcker om det.
Jag tror att vi också var väldigt medvetna om att inte nämna AI för annars hade det sin nästa bok på GL.
Det skulle bli så otroligt obsolet.
Jag är ganska glad över att den skrevs innan chat-GPT och innan jag kunde bli så lat så hade jag bara pratat i boken.
Så jag blev stolthet för min egen del.
Så processen blev att skriva på riktigt.
Men den här nya boken, den är bara chat-GPT och intalade prompt, så kan det inte vara det du är med i.
Det finns en sanning i det, jag tror att man inte är dum i huvudet.
Men sanningen är att vi sitter och skriver med två akademiker.
Så de bygger på deras forskning med Patrik och Malin.
För detta är inte du och Arash utan du och två forskare.
Exakt, precis så.
Deras forskning är gjord i forskningens konst, sen hänvisar vi till annan forskning.
Sen har jag och Patrik testat den grejen.
Det här forskningen som vi läst ut till idag, vi låter som du och jag gör nu.
Så har vi skrivit upp delarna vi vill få in, vi sitter och diskuterar det, låter, jämmer ni, lyssnar på allting, transkriberar och skriver ett kapitel om det.
Det funkar ganska bra.
Vilket coolt sätt att skriva på.
Ja, jag gillar det.
Teoridelarna är handskrivna, de andra delarna är pratade.
Och sen så lägger vi på ett lag.
Det känns som att AI för oss nu, förut var det att AI valde ut vad vi skulle se.
Men om vi människor skapade det som skulle ses, nu skapar ni, kreatar AI, och vi kurerar från vad AI kreatar, eller skapar vad som faktiskt är vettigt att presentera i mitt eget namn.
Så det är en skum process, ganska kul, men ganska skumt process.
Jag älskar det, jag har aldrig tänkt på det så, men det är klart att man skulle kunna göra så.
Ganska ofta sitter man i en dialog med någon, och så tänker man bara, fan det här är bra, det här hade man kunnat, och sen glömmer man ju av det, så glömmer man hur man formulerade det, så glömmer man era diskussioner, och så sätter man sig innan jag ska skriva, och så är det bara, nej, skit i det.
Det är ett jävligt häftigt sätt att skriva, speciellt den sortens böcker.
Ja, men vi tycker det är spännande och, ja, och sen så, ja.
Men hur är skillnaden att skriva en bok med, för nu känner inte jag Arash, men när jag har lyssnat på hans podd några gånger, och den är ju extremt filosofisk.
Han är ju väldigt så tankgod liksom, och sen så har vi ett par forskare som jag tänker generalisera till, så här, ja, den här siffran två är större än siffran ett.
Hur är skillnaden att skriva med de här två olika människorna?
Ja, men exakt, den stor skillnaden är ju, eller, likheten är väl att man båda vill liksom bottna sig i någon form av litteratur, om man får det jag har sagt.
Sen så är, jag och Arash skrev ju mycket mer från stream of consciousness.
Alltså att vi liksom, vår erfarenhet, jag riktade alltid det jag skrev till ledare jag haft som inte har förstått i handel.
Alltså så här, kom igen nu, så här funkar det.
Alla gånger som jag har gått och behövt få pengar till ett projekt på Apotheke Hjärtat eller någon stor organisation och bara återigen förklara att det här håller på att hända.
Medan den här nya då är det verkligen så, vi ser i datan.
Ser vi inte också i datan, min erfarenhet stämmer inte med den här datan.
Om Joel ska kunna använda sig av det här så måste vi se vad han ska göra av det.
Då kan det vara vertilektion, men det här finns ingen evidens för.
Och det är därför de har tagit in mig, för det kan vara en röst som inte kräver att evidens finns.
Utan jag är mer råd och rön gubbe och så håller de kvar.
Det är ju kug, det blir en ganska spännande dynamik.
Mellan sunt förnuft och evidens.
Det tar lång tid att skapa evidens.
Det är exakt samma sak som att enligt arbetssätt kan gå ganska fort, men att det är en IT-system att ta lång tid, det krävs flera år att verkligen bevisa att det här är det bästa sättet att spyrna en kategori på.
Och den tiden har ju inte en retailer.
Men är det positivt att blanda två olika på det sättet?
Blir det inte bara ingenting av det?
Eller alltså, jag bara menar, när du berättar dina erfarenheter sånt där, då kanske man kan koppla det.
Men sen om man ska lägga in forskning och det är lite annorlunda, så blir det såhär, fan ska jag försöka göra något i mitten då?
Mitten är ju sällan kanske det bästa.
Eller, eller...
Nej men det är bra, vi försöker använda det mer som någon form av dynamik.
Alltså just det och i, och därmed dynamik är väl liksom att det blir en spänningfält mellan två ytor.
Så att vi försöker liksom skapa någon form av kontrast kanske.
Och snarare än att ligga oss i mellanmjölk.
Utan att man kommer nog att höra ganska tydligt vilken röst, alltså det kommer inte att stå såhär Nick säger, men man kommer nog att höra ganska tydligt vilka röster som har pratat, eller skrivit, pratat kanske då i och för sig.
Jag fattar det, jag gillar det, det är lite spännande.
Så jag hoppas att det inte blir, det är jättebra poäng, jag hoppas verkligen inte att det blir mellanmjölksläget.
Men jag tror, jag själv tycker ju, jag tror att det kan vara lite nice för en retailer att läsa det här och känna sig lite smak.
Alltså typ såhär, aha, forskningen tycker såhär och såhär om det.
Okej men hur ska man, och då får man, allt sådana här litteraturer är ju till för att skapa idéer hos läsaren så att de kan nyttja det i sin vardag.
Det är liksom, det är det som är grejen.
Alltså det är inte många som kommer läsa pastverksforskning eller doktorsavhandling, men det här är ju mer såhär, aha, okej man kan tänka på det här sättet.
Och om ditt fönster vidgas lite grann och du tar ett lite annorlunda beslut som tog dig lite närmare till målet, då har man ju lyckats.
Och det vet jag inte om vi lyckats med men det är det som är målet för oss med boken.
Ja, men för den som sagt, du har ju sagt att den ska heta kundjävlar och du verkar drivas av kundbeteendet och kundgrejerna.
Finns det några såhär, du behöver inte säga tre bra grejer med kund, men finns det några missuppfattningar som du alltid tycker att vi som säljer saker har om kunder?
Är det något som du bara korkade människor i exempel?
Det finns ju både och.
Det är en sak med kundresan som både är korkad och smart.
Men när vi ritar upp en kundresa så ritar vi alltid någon form av average-kundresa.
Vad de flesta gör och de flesta går igenom den och att den går relativt linjerärt.
Alla företag gör det här.
Och så hittar vi fel utav pengar för kunden, du försöker förstå hur kunden mår i varje läge och blablabla.
Och sen när vi landar in i att ingen kund rör sig så.
Men av någon konstig anledning så fungerar det ju.
För även om de inte rör sig så så kommer den här painen i just den här delen av processen kommer kunder känna av och vi vill ju få dem att röra sig vidare.
Så det är två ägget.
Vi försöker hålla båda de här idéerna om att kunder faktiskt inte rör sig så i liv samtidigt som vi försöker använda hur nyttjar vi det här så mycket som möjligt.
En stor risk som vi ändå ser hos många är att vi i alla fall i svensk e-handel är att det är så otroligt konverteringsoptimerat.
Och att man bara försöker ta bort friktion.
Där vissa mogna e-handlare försöker skapa rätt friktion snarare.
Och då, om i rätt friktion, det kan ju vara allt liksom där.
Det här friktionen skapar gjorde så att vi fick färre returer, men det tappade konverteringen och på helheten klarade vi oss av med det.
Men alltså att lägga till ett fält på dina skor som säger så att du får inte köpa både 42 och 43.
Det är ju ren friktion mot kunden som kommer säkert garanterat tappa konvertering på.
Men du kommer också halvera dina returer för att de får bara köpa en storlek av den här skorna.
Det är ett exempel på ökad friktion i kundresan som är positiv.
Sen finns det andra exempel på...
Men när du menar friktion, menar du grejer som i slutändan gör det lönsamt?
Du menar inte som att bibehålla kund på hemsidan utan du menar...
Nej, jag menar nog friktion som gör att det är lite tuffare för kunden att komma igenom kundresan.
Om vi skulle gjort ett A-B-test på de här två, så skulle vi se att många fler kommer till nästa steg när man följer in båda.
Jag förstår, men hos oss hade det kunnat vara till exempel, vi säljer en del reservdelar och sånt där, nu har vi inte dem online utan vi ofta kurerar via telefon, men om man hade det online så skulle det kunna vara att i sista steget när du har valt in, då kommer en kundtjänstmedarbetare in i chatten och ställer några kontrollfrågor och kollar att det växer ner.
Okej, jag förstår, du dödar lite konvertering, men du skapar större chans att det blir rätt då.
Ja, exakt.
Det här är ett ganska självklart exempel att det är fördelen för företaget.
För allt när man gör konverteringsoptimering så måste man ha några nyckeltal som absolut inte får rubbas.
Och då kan det vara att returgraden får göra vad du vill på sajten, men marginalen och returgraden får inte bli sämre.
Och då får du göra det här.
Om någon skulle ta bort den här grejen som vi pratar om nu med skorna, då skulle returgraden fukkas även om AB-testet visar att det var värt att göra det.
Jag hade bara stängt av hemsidan och så hade jag gjort en mic drop och så...
Ingenting var förrädd, jag kände att jag kunde ta mina pengar och dra.
Exakt, det är verkligen att ta lite blank och låna och sticka.
Det är en spännande tanke, för så brukar man inte tänka.
Har du nån mer sån här, nu behöver du inte komma på nån mer, men har du nån mer sån tanke?
Nej men...
Får jag fråga en annan innan du...
Förlåt.
Du sa också att vi generaliserar kundresan.
Finns det, du sa också att alla gör så, men hur skulle vi annars göra det?
Finns det något bra annat sätt att göra det på?
Alternativet blir att man gör olika resor, men det blir också typ, okej vi gjorde tio olika, det blir bara en jävla massa extra.
Nej, precis.
Det är väl liksom det som vi alla tror att det kommer att bli en sån här ultra personalisering nu, så att vi faktiskt orkar och kan lösa alla de här olika kundresorna linjärt.
Samtidigt vill vi läsa dem så som vi vill att de ska vara lösta för att vi finns teknik för det.
Men jag vet inte, där finns fantasier och idéer om det, men det får vi se om det blir någonting av det.
Men en annan sak som du är...
Det är svårt att veta hur man ska dokumentera det annorlunda.
Det bästa sättet jag sett det är att man får ut olika arbetsområden.
Vi förstår att kunden...
Om många kunder har väldigt lite erfarenhet, eller väl lite awareness av ditt varumärke, då blir det så här att vi måste skapa upp awarenessen.
Det behöver inte skada någonting annat i kundresan.
Det här är mitt serverarexempel som jag alltid drar.
Där såg jag att en massa e-handlare började använda sig av Out of Home för e-handeln.
Jag bara är det det som ska hända nu?
Är det inte performance marketing?
Varför börja...
Och det var stora e-handlare som Lyko till exempel.
Då säger de att det är okej, servera i den här Out of Home.
Då kanske vi är på en bra plats där, för det här är trenden.
Men sen pratade jag med de här e-handlarna.
De var bara 6-7 procent som vet om vad vi är för varumärke, även de som är stora nu.
Men alla som hittar oss köper 15-20 gånger om året hos oss.
Deras produkt fungerade finbra, priset var rätt, produkten var rätt, de komporterade rätt, de kommunicerade rätt.
Längre bak i tratten var det asmäktigt.
Medan på servera köpte man 1,3 gånger per år på e-handeln.
Men alla vi som serverade var.
Så då blev min uppgift att jag inte kommer att bry mig om awareness alls.
För fokus är ju liksom, du enda du vet är att vara resurserändlig.
Och då blev jag allt fokus på vår sajt, men också på Fyra Pena, alltså produktplatspris och promotion.
Och det hjälpte ju mig i mitt fokus och jag kunde dra ner aktierna lite grann för att en del var faktiskt väldigt bra.
Är det svårt att komma ifrån det i tankesätt?
Jag tänker att det är ganska vanligt att man tittar på framgångsrika.
Vi tar Lyko eftersom du tog det som exempel.
Går det lätt att blästa upp annonser utomhus?
För det var ju en grej som de blev kända för typ.
Men det behöver inte alls vara för oss.
Och så lägger man massa tid och energi.
Du hoppar ju mellan olika företag.
Är det svårt för dig att nollställa huvudet mellan varje så att du inte blir färgad?
Ja, absolut.
Nu har jag varit i så mycket olika kategorier.
Och det finns, jag tycker att det är den saker som avgör mest dynamiken på hur du ska tänka kring just kundresan.
Det är egentligen snittåddevärdet, har jag liksom insett.
För om du har ett extremt högt snittåddevärde, då är kundresan väldigt mycket långsammare.
Och kunderna är mycket längre i den utforskande fasen.
Och då finns det mer behov av att vara top of mind.
Men det finns även behov av att vara top of mind.
Men om du har ett lågt kundvärde, lågt återvärde, och lågt återvärde översätter jag också till att du köper produkten oftare.
Då kan du börja bygga en lojalitet där du kan vara mycket mer transaktionell.
För att du kan få kunder att köpa varje månad.
Alltså har du lykosfall eller har du haft ett hjärtatsfall eller?
Räknas tre som en högt kundvärde, eller högt återvärde eller lågt, för det är ju en månad.
Abonemang är ju ett eget djur nästan.
Okej.
Så att, men absolut det här är det.
Och där finns ju ett riktigt lojalitet genom att du är bundad till och med.
Det är inte riktig lojalitet men det är på pappret, sann lojalitet för du är bundad.
Du är inte bundad att köpa dina nästa stolar hos Nordic Nest, för att du köpte dem den första gången.
Utan du kommer ju vara mer lojal till stoltypen du köpte, för att du behöver sex stolar.
Du har köpt fyra och du behöver två till, liksom du behöver sex stolar.
Så det här är ju mer lojal till marknader.
Det finns en annan dynamik där men absolut, det här kräver en plastitiset i huvudet.
Det kräver en stor skillnad på kundservice.
I Nordsjögaleriet till exempel så ringde kunderna in, nästan varje order så ringde en kund in också.
Så det var ju nästan mer som att vi hade ett en katalog digitalt, där kunderna ville lägga en order digitalt, men de ville också ringa in.
Så det var ju telefonförsäljning och digitalt.
Medan på apk1 var det kanske 3-4% av alla order som blev ett kundservice samtal.
Och då var det ju vi som uppmanade till dem för att det var receptbelagt.
Och ändå var det bara 3-4%.
Så det här är också en relation.
För att man av den anledningen att ena saker kostar 20 000 och köpa, det andra kostar 400 och köpa.
Och du lägger mycket mer energi på det här 20 000 kronor köpet.
Så det ordervärdet är det.
Du generaliserar sönder, alltså klart.
Det finns jättemånga munt och tag för det här.
Men det här är en sån sak som jag använder mig av för att förstå hur kundresan andras och hur du tror att relationell eller relationell du ska vara med din kundresa.
Jag tycker det är ett bra exempel och ganska tydligt till varför vi tar vissa beslut som vi gör.
Vi är till exempel relationella då.
Vi pratar ju med...
Vårt snittårdvärde ligger på typ 5 000.
Men av dem så är det rätt många som lägger bara något handtag eller någon grej så de försvinner.
De lägger bara på hemsidan.
Det är väldigt många ordrar över 10, 15, 20 000 och de ringer alla och har diskussioner.
Sedan får vi ofta den här varför kör ni inte in kosttillsgott, typ proteinpulver eller liknande.
Det finns massa andra anledningar till det men det är också en helt annan kundresa.
Det är klart att vi kan sälja det vid sidan av men det är ett annat affär som går.
Precis och det är en annan logistik.
Det är mycket mer influencer och så vidare.
Men just det här med kundsupporten är väldigt annorlunda.
Det här är vis, jag vet inte hur många gånger jag har sprungit in i nya produktkategorier och fått backa, inte så många gånger men flera gånger, för att inte analysen var klar liksom.
Det är så jävla lätt att missa någon punkt där eller vertikaler, vad man ska kalla det.
Och så bara, det är helt annorlunda än det där.
Men jag skulle också vilja prata om, du sitter i lite styrelser och har suttit i en del, vad är det för roll, jag är väldigt fascinerad av styrelser, vad gör de liksom?
Varför finns de?
Vad fyller du för funktion i en styrelse och vad tycker du att styrelsen ska fylla för en podd?
Ja men exakt, jag sitter i ganska små styrelser så jag tror att det är väldigt stor skillnad om, de bolagen omsätter mellan 100 och 400 miljoner ungefär.
Ja, bara 400 miljoner, fan vad pissigt.
Vilket jävla skitbolag.
Nej men jag tror att det här är jättestor skillnad om du skulle fråga någon som sitter i någon börsbolag eller stort börsbolag.
De lyssnar inte på den här forden.
Men nej, säg inte det.
Jag är ju oftast den digitala kompetensen i styrelsen.
Samtidigt måste jag förstå det ekonomiska.
Jag förstår ju hela årsredovisningen, PNL-
och cashflowet.
Man har ju de ansvaret.
Om jag inte hade varit rent IT-utvecklare eller innovatör, då hade jag nog skonat mig själv att inte vara i styrelsen alls.
Jag drivs ju av att få de här nyckeltappalen att flyga.
Men jag översätter det till digitala initiativ eller digital kraft i styrelsen.
Det som jag också upptäcker att jag gör, det är att jag möjliggör för vd-en att lyssna på den digitala kompetensen som de har faktiskt tagit in i bolaget.
Det är många bolag som har tagit in en e-handelschef eller tagit in en affärsdirektorschef som ska göra det digitalt.
Sen går de ändå in i sina mönster och då finns det ett tryck ovanifrån som de själva valt såklart.
Men det finns ett tryck underifrån också och så kan det hjälpas åt.
Man håller den agendan i liv i styrelserummet så att man inte tappar det fokuset.
Sen gör man Java C24 eller fem gånger om året.
Jag är ofta med och håller några workshops med teamet också.
Om de ska göra något stort i IT-byte så är jag ofta med och träffar leverantörer när jag är med på RSPN.
Så jag är ganska mycket hansson ändå.
Hela tiden är jag lite för hansson för att vara den optimala styrelsemedlemmen.
Men det beror på vilket företag det är.
Vissa tycker att det är en dröm.
Jag är ofta bara för att ta inget kostnad timmar för det.
Så det är lite passionstriven på de här områdena.
Men själv då, vad tänker du om styrelser?
Jag kan uppleva att styrelsen när det är sådana små bolag som är mitt, och då menar jag egentligen att det inte är så mycket komplexitet.
Så egentligen är det inte bundet till omsättning.
Jag kan tycka att om ett företag är ett enkelt företag, alltså processerna är enkla och jobbet i sig är enkelt, och det är liksom inte så komplexa, arbetet är inte komplex, då har jag svårt att se vad styrelsen ska göra typ.
Det är väl bara att vi inte är där egentligen, men det är därför jag är så fascinerad av det, för det känns som att det är så etablerat att man ska ha en styrelse.
Jag försöker liksom hitta, jag försöker se vad det är jag missar, vad det är jag...
Jag förstår.
Jag frågar alltid ut folk som sitter i styrelsen, vad det är de pysslar med liksom.
Nej precis, om det är bra, jag är ju bara styrelsemedlem, jag är inte styrelseutförande och har bara varit...
Det finns styrelseutförande som jag jobbar med, de är ju väldigt duktiga på att hålla ordning och reda.
Jonas som har varit på peak, han sitter där igen, styrelseutförande är inte av bolagen jag är med i.
Det är bara mycket värde genom att ha nånen på det här, har ni koll på cashflowet?
Det blir någon som blir ansvarig, du hålls ansvarig helt enkelt.
Men vad fan gör vdn?
Nej men exakt, det är bara att...
Är det bara en lös person som går runt och dricker kaffe?
Nej, nej, för dem.
Okej, ordförande håller vdn ansvarig, okej.
Så om du har den pressen på dig själv, i den fas som du är i nu, då är det säkert inte nödvändigt.
Vissa tycker att man ökar hastigheten av styrelsen, vissa tycker att man appar hastigheten för att man behöver mer struktur.
Det är snarare...
Om du är din funktion, då skulle...
Det är dyrt av styrelse också, så det är absolut inte alltid nödvändigt.
Men det är det som du behöver som stöd.
Men om du är private equity act, då är det mer så att ägarna måste ha en röst in.
Då finns det mer naturliga förklaringar vad som har styr sig.
Ja.
Du pratade lite kort om i början att du brände dig som entreprenör när du var ung.
Jag skulle bara...
Det har varit lite intressant att få som slutklän här.
Kommer du aldrig starta nåt eget?
Nej men jo, det finns en dröm om det.
Som ni har sagt, jag vet inte vad det är som håller mig tillbaka riktigt, men det är nån form av självförtroende som man saknar.
För mig är det lite svårt att se ingenting till att skapa nånting, så jag skulle behöva en entreprenör att göra det med, som man skulle knyta an, tror jag.
Samtidigt har jag precis fyllt 40, min farfar var entreprenör nere i Tyskland, och han startade sitt företag när han var 40, och det finns kvar fortfarande.
Jag vet inte om jag har fokus på honom eller inte så mycket relation med honom, men det har alltid varit en bild att starta företaget när man är 40.
Och jag tror ju att alla idéer är gratis, så det är inte att sitta och leta på den optimala idén, utan idéerna är gratis, det är execution, det är det enda.
Det är det enda jag skulle bry mig om.
Och där tror jag att jag är ganska duktig på att exekvera, men så att jag får se, det kanske dyker upp någonting åt det hållet och ändå eller också.
Och speciellt vid återfyller 15-16, de blir mer flygående, eller fyller 14 men även de blir 15-16 under den här perioden.
Vi får se.
Vad tycker du själv då, varför är du entreprenör?
Jag ska inte ha massa frågor, men jag kan, jag tror inte jag kan låta bli, jag tror att man har lite olika, alltså folk har olika drivkrafter, vissa verkar säga att jag ska bevisa, jag ska göra det här, jag ska bli rik och jag ska sånt här.
För mig, jag har liksom inga andra intressen, jag kan liksom inte, jag kan inte bli intresserad av något annat.
Detta är det jag sysslar med och det liksom, du vet när jag går hem från jobbet, jag är klar och jag stänger ner, då är jag ju med mina barn men sen när de går och lägger sig, då skoj jobbar jag på kvällen och då sitter jag med företaget och så här, jag jobbar för skojskor, jag har inget annat, jag vill bara bygga bolag, jag vill inte göra något annat.
Jag tycker inte det är kul.
Vad ska jag syssla med annars?
Men nu är det inte riktigt att det är ett bevis, eller att du undemot, jag anöjer ju om dig men såhär, eller att du vill bli rik eller är det, eller är ni liksom, är ni värda till bolaget?
Det finns säkert någon maktfullkomlighet i grunden, det gör det väl hos de flesta människor, men jag kan, va fan, nu hamnar vi här i alla fall.
Jag kan uppleva att jag slösade bort, ja men det är trevligt när människor är trevliga, men när, jag liksom kastade bort mycket tid när jag var ung, fram tills jag var typ 26.
Du vet jag hade väldigt lätt för mig i skolan, jag tror inte jag har pluggat på ett enda prov, och jag hade, jag har alltid klarat mig och alltid såhär, så att, men för sådana människor blir det ju ofta ganska mycket skit, till slut, för att man har det för lite simpelt i sånt där.
Och då vaknade jag upp en dag och bara, fan jag har ju inte gjort någonting av det jag kan liksom, så att då fick jag ta tag i livet och så bara bestämde jag mig för då, nu tänker jag liksom inte sakta ner förrän jag känner att jag kommer i kapp, och jag är fortfarande långt ifrån i kapp där jag borde vara liksom, så att det är bara jobba på i många många många år till.
Intressant, fastgönt, ja, coolt.
Det får bli en egen podd någon gång.
Ja verkligen, den där, jag kan inte göra det i omgång.
Det var grovt generaliserat tycker jag.
Jag förstår det, jag hänfattar det, men det var ändå en väldigt fin ingång.
Och spännande.
Du, Nick.
Innan vi byter, det märks att, vill ni lyssna på Nick, kan ni lyssna på det här i Anders podden där han är med.
Då ställer han insiktsfulla frågor till folk.
Men, stort tack för att du var med i podden, och tack för, jag tror jag hade tre eller fyra sådana här tillfällen när jag var tvungen att stanna upp och bara, fan, så kan man ju tänka liksom.
Fan vad nice.
Ja, vad kul.
Ja, så jag hoppas många människor fick med sig mycket info och, vad roligt.
Vi ser fram emot nästa bok.
Det är väldigt kul att vara med.
Ja, det ska bli superroligt, så den kommer september och oktober någon gång.
Jag sätter press på mig själv genom att säga det högt, så att, ja.
Exakt, då ser vi till att ha med dig, Kristoffer.
Tack så mycket.
Vad pysslar du med, vad jobbar du med nu?